you do not have to eat cheese okay you
do not have to eat them cuz they're
actually from cuz they're all 1999 yeah
they're all ah
all food consumed was done so
voluntarily BuzzFeed does not condone
the eating of episode 1 snacks from 1999
do not attempt it on this box is faded
is never a good thing when you're trying
to eat a food source wait let's do the
math 1999 so these are 16 years old I'm
gonna bore you dusty this has Jar Jar
Binks all over it he's literally the
worst I think at the time they actually
thought people would like George Evans
before the movie came out they were
wrong in the biggest way possible in the
color of this ah please dude it's like
parchment paper like alight Alexandria
dude are you kidding me oh my god maybe
I'm rethinking yeah good I want it wrong
it looks like Yoda took a hit on this
paper what's on the top oh god no it's
that tastes good but smells terrible are
you serious hmm it smells nice I don't
know about that it's like nice with a
little bit of rotten oh good smells like
my grandpa shoes I mean you gotta try it
there you ain't it Oh what's terrible
idea don't eat it tastes like watermelon
actually pretty good we going are you
really eating it it's like if you
marinated a watermelon piece of candy
from today and just like a an ashtray
for a little while I don't know
just ancient artifacts the detail on
these jellies are a maze-like spared no
expense back in 1999 we're getting no Oh
Anakin out loved to eat his stupid face
oh oh the colors are gone I could
probably kill somebody with this yeah oh
my gosh I can't even squeeze it they're
all brown see this smell weird and like
but they smell fruity still I picture
they have a curve it is I bet you these
are still good these can't be good are
they there these were supposed to be
just kidding I can't do it oh you gotta
use your mowers I feel like it'll pull
up my filling it might it's very odd
flavor it actually tasted like an eraser
this just tastes like soap mr. Ravi fell
like 15 years of like dust packaging in
my mouth